qu'on se le dise il ne fait aucun doute
que ce jeune garçon est bel et bien le
héros de la semaine
en plus d'un exploit physique intense ce
jeune garçon a fait ça pour la bonne
cause
christophe à crawley pour octobre rose
ce mois de sensibilisation au cancer du
sein
dans le cadre d'octobre rose le
mouvement de sensibilisation pour lutter
contre le cancer du sein
un jeune garçon de 12 ans a décidé de
rejoindre à la nage l'état insulaire de
st lucie et la martinique une distance
de plus de 40 km 13h59 et 47 secondes
dans la mer si le jeune christophe mano
s'est surpassé c'est en trouvant le
courage de s'accrocher pour son combat
et à des moments où j'ai douté mais je
me suis dit c'est pour la bonne cause on
doit continuer une rage qui s'explique
en partie par le fait que sa propre mère
avec des victimes de cette maladie il y
aura fallu un peu moins de 14 heures
pour rejoindre les deux rives
[Applaudissements]
décrivez comme celle de ce jeune garçon
de 12 ans 40 km à la nage ses années aux
40 km trésor dans l'eau ah ouais c'est
ça on est d'accord on sait que pour sa
maman qui l'a fait départ et après pour
le collectif
un petit garçon en or franchement
effectivement vraiment où sa maman et
puis j'ai appris en plus que ce n'était
pas son premier défi premier défi en
2017 il avait 9 ans à 9 ans il nage déjà
6 4 km et en 2018 il s'attaque aux 26 km
entre le diamant et cherchant des
chercheurs étrangers cette chère aux
distinctions des chercheurs effet quand
on adhère
d'abord il est adorable c'est c'est le
petit super héros du moment martinique
tout le monde en parle ça veut dire vers
des milliers de personnes pour pour
l'accueillir pour l'acclamer l'applaudir
je les urnes ont alloué ouais il vous
fait de gros bisous je t'embrasse
moyenne ces gros bisous à toi vraiment
l'émission ma vie de remercier toutes
les équipes et surtout faut savoir que
ça fait deux ans déjà qu'ils
s'entraînent pour pour cette traversée
par ce que c'est si travers ce qui est
très difficile il ya un canal qui
s'appelle le canal de sainte-lucie entre
les deux îles qui en bateau et
infogrames parce que tout le monde des
gobies c'est insupportable et lui
demande juste en fait aujourd'hui que
des adultes à l'instar de son père et
son entraîneur prennent les rêves des
petits au sérieux et aide les enfants à
réaliser leur rêve c'est magnifique
vraiment on t'embrasse très très haut
were vraiment vraiment vraiment